[Musik]
in den november 2008 10 war es in der
meerenge von kertsch zu einem
militärischen zusammenstoß zwischen
russland und der ukraine gekommen
russische schiffe vom grenzschutz rampen
und beschossen ukrainische marineschiffe
die meerenge wurde blockiert und 24
ukrainische matrosen wurden verhaftet
heute in vechta kompakt das ringen und
dassow chemie
[Musik]
was ist passiert die ukrainische marine
wollte drei patrouillenboote von odessa
nach mario pulver legen dass sie keine
durchfahrt genehmigung hatten wurden sie
von der russischen küstenwache gestoppt
und in weiterer folge beschossen
über den genauen hergang gibt es
unterschiedliche und widersprüchliche
darstellungen aber das war zu erwarten
zum hintergrund ende 2003 hatten moskau
und kiew den vertrag über die
zusammenarbeit bei der nutzung des
asowschen meeres und der straße von
kertsch geschlossen
schon zu sowjetzeiten galt deshalb
spinnen mehr sorgen aktuellen vertrag
dieser sichert kriegs und
handelsschiffen beider länder die freie
durchfahrt den beiden gewässern ohne
einschränkung oder zustimmung des
jeweils anderen staates durch 2014 hat
sich die lage grundlegend geändert es
kam zum turbulenten machtwechsel in kiew
russland annektierte die grimm und im
dom baus flanken heftige kämpfe auf
moskau unterstützt seit aufstands beginn
die rebellen im osten der ukraine baute
eine brücke vom russischen festland auf
die krim und kontrolliert seit mitte
2018 den zugang in das offene meer
somit ist der vertrag aus 2003 de facto
außer kraft
für eine einschätzung des ereignisse
sind drei faktoren besonders relevant
erstens russische gebietsansprüche durch
der annexion der krim beansprucht
russland die zwölf meilen zone als
territorialgewässer und die
ausschließliche wirtschaftszone ein
wichtiger faktor angesichts der
erheblichen gas und ölvorkommen in dem
gebiet
außerdem fallen nach auffassung des
kremls die obergrenzen zur stationierung
von streitkräften auf der halbinsel weg
zweitens wirtschaftliche schwächung der
ukraine
der bau der brücke ermöglicht dass
moskau den verkehrsweg lückenlos zu
kontrollieren
jedes schiff muss sich anmelden und auf
tage lang auf eine durchfahrts
genehmigung warten
sie dürfen maximal 31 meter 13 und nur
33 meter über das wasser ragen
riesen frachtern bleibt daher der weg
von vorneherein versperrt das schadet
vor allem der ukrainischen wirtschaft
die etwa 20 prozent der stahlproduktion
auf diesem weg exportiert so ist der
schiffstransport aus mario pohl den
wichtigsten
zwischen hafen im osten seit mai 2018 um
ein viertel gesunken
dritter aspekt ausbau der ukrainischen
marine im osten
infolge der einverleibung der krim
verlor die ukraine etwa 80 prozent ihrer
flotte sie ist bemüht diese mit
unterstützung der usa wieder aufzubauen
dabei geht es auch um marine kapazitäten
im asowschen meer um dort eine totale
russische dominanz zu verhindern
daher möchte kiew den marinestützpunkt
im biathlon zu einer basis aufbauen
welche reaktionen gab es auf den vorfall
die ukraine hat das vorgehen als
kriegerischen akt angeprangert und in
einigen bezirken für 30 tage den
kriegszustand ausgerufen
russland auf kiew eine grenzverletzung
vor und vermutete eine provokation des
ukrainischen präsidenten im wahlkampf
punkten zu können
reaktionen von internationaler seite der
sicherheitsrat der uno hat unverzüglich
getagt und vor einer eskalation genannt
eine vermittlung durch deutschland und
frankreich im sogenannten normativ
format bezeichnete russland als nicht
erforderlich
die oecd forderte zurückhaltung und
empfahl politische und diplomatische
lösungsansätze
die eu verurteilte außerdem das
völkerrechtswidrige vorgehen russlands
hier versuchte die nato schiffe in das
schwarze meer zu entsenden
durch diese beschränkte sich darauf das
russische verhalten als provokation zu
werden und betonte die gute kooperation
mit der ukraine alle akteure waren
sichtlich an einer entspannung
interessiert ein ausblick die
grundlegenden probleme können in
absehbarer zeit nicht beseitigt werden
moskau wird weiterhin seine
territorialen ansprüche festigen und
wirtschaftlichen druck auf die ukraine
ausüben und kiew wird aus einer
territorialen integrität und
souveränität bewahren
der beschuss der boote hat gezeigt wie
angespannt die lage zwischen russland
und der ukraine ist weitere vorfälle
sind keinesfalls auszuschließen
es wird daher viel diplomatisches
geschick erforderlich sein und
pragmatische ansätze zu finden die
zumindest ein gewaltfreies nebeneinander
ermöglichen